hélas là c'est un nouveau monde valérie
plan bonsoir mais la zone ont rien fait
la même réaction puis les mêmes
réactions que l'an dernier
ouais ouais ben on les a entendu les
montréalais c'est clair avant on va
parler des commerçants dans une seconde
mais pas nulles résidentiel 1,1 mouvant
le tableau 1,7
mais ça c'était quoi le plus bord vous
pouviez à lille si je comprends oui
effectivement 1,7 l'os et c'est sur le
taux d'inflation le point le taux de
l'inflation en ce moment et à 1,1672
donc on est dessus
et puis ça inclut temps là la taxe
centrale que la taxe d'arrondissement
donc la moyenne ça fait 1,7 pour cent
donc pour nous mais on est très
satisfait c'est vraiment notre objectif
cette année est bon le commercial 1,3 ça
plus bon revoir la donne est arrivé mais
là il ya beaucoup de commerçants qui
sont et qui a depuis des années parce
que la charge fiscale
les taxes pour les commerçants c'est
s'est accrue la différence on avait un
reportage hier avec la moyenne
canadienne ou si l'écart est important
ça coûte plus cher proportionnellement
pour recommencer à montréal que pour un
commerçant ailleurs au pays on voit les
chiffres le 37-28 113 à montréal 24 21
c'est énorme et oui faut écouter un
petit extrait de monsieur lozeau quel
magasin bien connu ceinture verte qui
avait dit certaines félicitations vous
faire aujourd'hui mais il dit là c'est
pas terminé la bataille on écoute reste
du cerveau rial parce que comme on
disait il n'y a pas encore de baisse de
taxes donc les prix vont rester à brest
amiens les routes les conditions que
tout le monde parle et qu'on orange
encore qu'il ne pourra grand boutin la
ville fait des efforts mais il faut
continuer à faire des efforts pour que
les entreprises restent et qui aussi les
gens viennent magasiner à montréal et
non pas qu'ils sortent la ville pour
aller magasiner juin vers d'autres pays
on a des l'échelonnement des paiements
etc ce qui n'est pas possible à montréal
donc on a un ou deux paiement maximum
car un crack d'autres villes ont un
échelonnement des paiements sur 12 mois
en partant déjà sauce avoir aidé une
grosse partie des collèges qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez répondre monsieur lauzon et
aux autres commerces inscrits à d'autres
manières vous n'avez pas encore mais sur
place la mine mais bien une opération
pour aider les commerçants oui c'est un
début et monsieur law a raison c'est que
ça fait des années et des années que la
taxation elle est difficile pour les
commerçants et on l'a bien compris puis
comme c'est notre premier budget on ne
peut plus contrôler toute l'année et les
dépenses et les revenus
on est capables de mettre nos priorités
de l'avant alors oui cette réduction de
taxe de 10% pour les commerces dont
l'évaluation foncière et de 500 milles
et moins et même aux déçus ça va être
très bénéfique également les petits
petit c'est vraiment une bouffée d'air
oui oui absolument parce que non pour
une commerçants ça lui coûte 450 me par
exemple pour son édifice ben il va avoir
une excuse et moins une bataille voilà à
peu près mille 600 dollars et ça c'est à
peu près presque 60% des des commerçants
lors que ces 2 500 mais les moins donc
c'est vraiment intéressant
ceci étant dit ça peut pas s'arrêter là
l'un des membres du milieu c'est
vraiment d'avoir une stratégie pour
diminuer l'écart entre le résidentiel et
le commercial et celle là dedans qu'on
s'engage donc on est vraiment dans une
mouvance on voulait poser un geste fort
c'est avec ce 10% de réduction de taxes
mais on va aller plus loin tout le temps
et l'échelonnement de pouvoir payer
parce que les résidences les citoyens
peuvent le faire maintenant ses rivaux
est ce que les commerçants pourront le
faire
doit on veut faire exactement la même
chose c'est ça l'idée c'est de pouvoir
faciliter le paiement pour tout le monde
parce qu'on sait que ça peut être lourd
dépendamment des différentes charges que
l'on est ce qu il yad autres entre
guillemets bonne nouvelle dans ce budget
là pour les montréalais je lisais dans
votre communiqué plus des espaces verts
etc
des packs vendée mois une partie jamais
régulièrement qu'on ne peut être passé
sous silence mais les espaces assez
majeur il faut savoir que auparavant il
y avait à peu près 5 millions de dollars
qui est investi pour réhabiliter ou
s'arrangent s'occuper des espaces verts
il faut savoir qu'à montréal on a un
objectif de préserver 10% des espaces
verts 10 pour ça ça fait des années
qu'on stania 6% alors on doit mettre les
bouchées doubles et nous on passe par
exemple de 1 5 millions à près de 60
millions de 20 millions par année sur
trois ans c'est énorme on va le voir ou
bayer des jeunes nous on a une stratégie
d'achat de terrain on pense entre autres
à l'ouest de montréal on passe à l'est
également
on veut saisir toutes les opportunités
puis-je faire vos premiers les berges
les berges très important pour acquérir
des espaces verts on est une île on est
très vulnérable aux changements
climatiques
on prend ça très au sérieux et sinon on
va investir des sommes colossales à part
56 millions $ pour des parcs locaux donc
dans les arrondissements chaque
arrondissement va pouvoir avoir un
million $ par année sur les prochaines
années pour pouvoir faire des
rénovations et des aménagements soient
sa touche à la qualité de vie des
citoyens et des familles oui tout à fait
mais pas au détriment non plus de projet
d'entreprise de musée pour centre ville
le jeu pour refaire tout mais il faut
qu'ils aient un équilibre suis c'est ma
mémé c'est faisable et on doit on peut
le faire il ya entre autres avec le
musée mccord bientôt on va pouvoir faire
une belle annonce parce que bien qu'on
ait changé le l'endroit céderait qu'on
ait décidé de se réapproprier un espace
pour en faire un espace vert parce que
c'est très minéral dans le centre ville
les îlots de chaleur pour les combattre
mais on va on a travaillé de concert on
a accompagné le musée mccord pour
trouver une nouvelle ère nouvelle un
nouvel endroit on jongle à la cmm donc
l'ancien des villes n'auraient sur l'île
à une nounou a ajouté pour les
automobilistes qui n'habitent pas sur
l'île le 50 $ d'immatriculation pour
mieux financer le transport en commun
vous vous êtes d'accord avec ce ne soit
pas juste les gens de l'est mais échoue
vers nous à montréal on l'a déjà cette
action la menace des gens donc nous là
ça nous je pensais que ça nous concerne
blanc oui oui mais c'est pas moi qui va
dire ou aux autres villes faites le mais
nécessairement les villes on a un souci
de pouvoir offrir de meilleurs services
de transport collectif
quand on parle là qu'on veut agir sur
l'environnement l'outil numéro un la
façon d'un gers et du transport
collectif
mais pour que les gens aient envie de
délaisser la voiture encore faut-il qu à
une offre
puis quand plus soit efficace alors pour
que les vl décide d'aller chercher d'une
version d'un financement c'est sûr que
moi je pense d accord avec ça et je
serai peut-être plus équitable que tout
le monde dans la grande région de
montréal paient le 52 là mais pourquoi
madame rouleau à cette réaction ont du
coup
il n'est pas dans notre intention
d'augmenter les taxes des citoyens
au contraire on veut remettre de
l'argent aux québécois ce pandore on
sait très bien que les municipalités ont
besoin de diversifier leurs sources de
financement
et il ya plusieurs avenues qui existe
bon alors là la porte est fermée pas mal
mais en fait
bon moi si québec veut nous donner plus
de financement pour le transport
collectif c'est pas moi qui va rechigner
latule met en demeure pas moins que si
les villes de la cmm décès d'ensemble de
mettre une taxe sur l'immatriculation
je dois avouer que c'est dans lol les
pouvoirs de la cmm c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne et c'est comme ça que comme
région mais la confiance est déjà
arrêtée mais écoutez ça sera un peu
malvenu dans la mesure où preformance à
l'étude lors alors on va laisser la cmm
faire sont étonnés encore une fois c'est
là enfin démarrer mairesse qui se
prononce là dessus mais c'est ça le but
de la cmm c'est d'abord des décisions
métropolitaine pour notre développement
métropolitain et est encore une fois une
question d'équité puis de vision et
l'ogc nice élément d'équité de vision
d'avenir d'abord des gestes concrets sur
l'environnement puis de pouvoir offrir
les transports collecté que tout
l'argent parle de 50 millions et 100
millions aille vraiment dans le
transport en commun saignements
saignements que ça soit vraiment un as
de l'argent dédié au transport collectif
faut être sérieux un moment donné et la
piste rond que kelly ville soit dans
cette mouvance de dire et il faut qu'on
trouve des solutions on peut pas
attendre encore une fois si québec vont
injecter plus d'argent on est d'accord
on a pas de risque à la négocie fac ça
tombe bien on madame la mairesse les
fleurs c'était le budget vos chiffres
sont bons ou te des promesses mais sur
la mobilité
c'est peut-être le pot on a l'impression
que ça avance pas votre projet de
débloquer montréal c'est votre temps oui
absolument
oui autant trop contraint au niveau du
transport actif ou nos projets pour la
mobilité par jean mach et des autobus
les projets la ligne bleue durable ça
avance mais c'est clair qu'au niveau de
la mobilité entre autres automobiles ou
des camionneurs c'est vraiment plus
difficile je prenais plein plein de
raisons on l'appelait pour l'heure
pourquoi c'est comme ça mais au final
moins le message que je faisais roman
est allé assez que oui on a mis des
les moyens en place mais faut redoubler
d'ardeur ce n'est pas suffisant est ce
qu'elles sont doit ralentir le le nombre
de chantiers parce que vous avez vous
avez ouvert cette porte le 7 mai on veut
évaluer on voit échelonné peut-être
passé respaud de pire mais c'est pas
tant que ça va être pire mais ça va être
plus long mais c'est ça mais c'est ça
qui est possible c'est quand on sait la
population nous dit non non non en fait
les fêtes les faits teulet mais en même
temps c'est très très lourd pour eux et
j'aime rappeler que sur l'ensemble des
chantiers à montréal en ce moment 25% ce
sont ceux de la ville 75%
c'est les grues un peu partout parce que
l'économie va bien puis on construit des
taux c'est sûr vous saviez sa campagne
quand j'ai fait ces promesses l'aide
débloquée montréal oui on savait là on
le savait moins un piége pas retomber
dans ce qu'on savait pas meilleur
demeure pas moins que énormément de
chantiers qui ont été mis qui ont été
retardés à cause du 375e sont arrivés
dans le calendrier alors on a aussi une
masse plus importante de chantiers meyer
demeure pas moins que pour moi dans
certains quartiers je pense entre autres
à jouer sans nous je pense à dans le
centre-ville de montréal où l'escouade
de mobilité là je sais que les gens les
voient peut-être pas mais il faut
vraiment un travail incroyable depuis
joué ses trois mille interventions et si
les voit pas parce que justement ils ont
trouvé une solution rapide mais ça ne
règle pas tout et on doit redoubler
d'ardeur dans le code et des comptes
placé la veille ou l'avant veille alors
personne ne travaille pas ça bloque une
voix y en a je peux vous faire une
essayant n'en conseille ces cinq ans oui
évidemment qu'il faut faire attention
parce que si ça me prend plus de temps
chantiers majeurs d'enlever des comptes
chez pas pour la nuit alors que la même
atteint doigts pour revenir un moment
donné une économie d'échelle également
une escouade de mobilité encore une fois
elle est livrée mans l'ol travaille avec
le centre de contrôle de la ville de
montréal avec les gens de la circulation
pour trouver des solutions à quel moment
vous allez décider si vous échouez sonné
en fait on a commencé avec les équipes
de la ville j'en ai parlé il ya quelques
semaines qu'ils sont en train de me
faire différents scénarios ok madame la
mairesse pourquoi c'est la gazette avait
ce matin son rapport sur l'état de nos
jeans pas du canada ça c'est montréal 27
milles 567 par kilomètre repas vers
faire une route c'est plus haut que
quand guy allemand tenait lui faxe
london sabri toronto comment ça se fait
que c'est plus cher mais une des raisons
très très simple et c'est vrai alors
c'est que nous ne les coûts de nos
travaux les échelons sur dix ans à
toronto ou même pas couverts on parle
qui s'échelonnent le coût de leurs
travaux sur à peu près 25 ans avec nous
on amortit sur dix ans donc c'est le
coût de financement oui j'y vais
absolument en effet plus avoir comme
avant non non non non ça c'est qu'après
ça si je vous cacherais pas on parle
économie qui va bien c'est sûr que la
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre j'en ai c'est
sûr que c'est pas toujours trouvé facile
de trouver des corps de travail pour
aller sur les chantiers
salo n'est pas que sur les coûts mais en
demeure pas moins que le plus la plus
grosse barrière dans ce cas là c'est
vraiment comme en échelonnant paiement
en terminant rapidement leur fameux
paintball puis vous dites moi mon mon
règlement est meilleur parce que quand
on identifie un chien dangereux on sent
le cube soit plus de bolt soit plus
important mais le pitbull qui a mordu
six personnes donc appris enfin il est
toujours vivant qu'on s'occupe à mort en
étant là on est un bref aller
vérification parce que pour moi c'est un
non sens ce chien lors et en t on il ya
un diagnostic était fait et il doit être
euthanasié
point à la ligne hélas il semble y avoir
une question d'identification par les
vétérinaires
la mairesse de montréal ont redit on
passe à l'acte donc on donne
l'autorisation
et pour nous là nous on ne bloque
absolument pas processus dans ce cas là
de la même façon que dès qu'un chien est
considéré comme étant dangereux s'il est
à risque et d'aider des règles
s'appliquent très très ferme ssh et
dangereux il doit être cuit parce que
c'est ce que vous disiez pour rendre
votre projet faisait nous ça va être
même plus efficace les gens peuvent
utilement les gens appellent d'ailleurs
wii est bon dans ce cas-ci là on est en
train de pousser pourquoi ça prend
autant de temps mais j'ai des exemples
ailleurs
j'en parlais ailleurs l'eau comme quoi
il ya un animal qui était atteint de
tana zié parce que et ça fait à peu près
un mois de ça parce que le chien était
considéré comme étant dangereux après
une analyse d'un de l'inspecteur en
comportement animalier donc mieux
pamiers âge là ya pas de will toujours
vivant le pillage pas qu'on veut
s'acharner que ce sujet non non non non
j'ai atteint mes pions réaction à sa
réaction et dans ce cas aussi pour moi
même s'ils avaient des recours qui
seraient pris aux on va pas défendre
l'indéfendable c'est hors de question
le replay merci d'être venus sur
d'autres plates à la prochaine au revoir
quand soir